Hey guys welcome back, thanks for joining me today on the King of Random. When I was a kid,
I often dreamed of being a spy like James Bond or Jason Bourne, and an
old-fashioned staple of the spy is being able to write secret messages from one person to another
There are a lot of different ways you can try and write secret messages, and the purpose of today's video is to try out three
Different types of invisible ink to see which one's work the best. The first type of invisible ink we'll try is lemon juice which is
Invisible until you hold it over a heat source
The second is a mixture of baking soda and water which is supposed to be revealed when you cover it in grape juice
the third Experiment is to try and use bleach as an ink and see if it will show up under black light
Let's get started.  For our first invisible ink test
We've got a couple of lemons. You could also buy the pre-squeezed lemon juice in bottles at the store that should work
Just as well. Let's cut our lemon in half and squeeze the juice out onto this plate
I think that looks like enough juice to be used for a lot of ink
Now let's take a piece of a bamboo skewer or a toothpick; dip it in the juice and try writing on our paper
Dip the bamboo skewer in the lemon juice so it has a little bit of a coating on it
And then use that as a stylus to write on a piece of paper
Let your lemon juice ink dry completely onto the paper
The lemon juice invisible ink is supposed to be activated by heat
you can use an incandescent light bulb, a lighter, or a stove to try and give some heat to your paper and
Bring out the secret message.
First I'm going to try this with the lighter. Of course you need to be very careful that you don't light your piece of paper on fire
With the heat moving evenly to reduce your risk of flames
Ooh
There we go you can clearly see the secret message. The flame did do a little bit of scorching on the paper in a couple of spots
so as I said you have to be very careful, or you could easily burn your secret message. That worked pretty
Well, I'm going to try a slight variation
I have here an old-fashioned fountain pen, and I'm going to try using the lemon juice as ink to write with this instead
Write our secret message
This time instead of using the lighter because it has such a high risk of lighting the paper on fire
I'm going to be using a glass top stove
Using a glass top stove gives us a nice even surface to heat our paper over
That was supposed to be the letter U and apparently I didn't have quite enough lemon juice on my pen
Our second method involves a mixture of baking soda and water as the ink and grape juice to reveal it
I've mixed up about one part water and one part baking soda here. Not all of the baking soda will dissolve
But hopefully it will work just fine for our invisible ink. I'll try using my fancy pen again to see if this works
Let's use a little bit of paper towel to blot off the excess water. I've got two different methods
I want to try to apply the grape juice
First I'm going to use a little bit on a paper towel and rub it over the lettering
Next I'm going to put some grape juice in this small spray bottle and spray it over what I've written
The lettering is a little bit visible, but it's not standing out a ton
Not bad. It's good as a juice let's see if it's good at a secret message revealer
Well that actually kind of worked
Sprayed it on and then maybe sprayed on a little bit too much, but
Amazing I wasn't too bad it brought out the color. It's sort of a darker grey
Maybe even a hint of blue in it. Maybe that's just from the juice. That works, okay
I don't think it revealed as well as the lemon juice does
But it's kind of fun to be able to use a second chemical to make the first one appear as an experiment
I'm also going to see what happens if we use our baking soda water mixture as ink and then hold it over the heat the
Way we did with the lemon juice
You can see a message trying to appear.
Oh
What a good secret message. Actually that turned out really well
That shows up very nicely. I think that's actually even darker than the lemon juice
Let's see what happens if we also put the heat over the one that had grape juice on it
That's cool, I don't know how well it showed on my camera, but all of the grape juice just turned like a lot more purple
And it started burning the paper so that wasn't as good
For our third type of invisible ink we're going to be using bleach and an ultraviolet flashlight
Ultraviolet is a frequency of light that we can't pick up very well with our eyes
But there are a lot of substances that will reflect it back in a frequency we can see
We can see
So let's carefully pour out a small amount of our bleach and try riding with it to see what happens
First let's see if the bleach itself seems to light up in the black light.
It doesn't seem to be doing much
Let's see if the bleach itself seems to light up in the black light doesn't seem to be doing much
Looks pretty much the same with the black light on it.  Well even though it's not lighting up very much on the plate
Looks pretty much the same with the black light on it well even though. It's not lighting up very much on the plate
Okay now in theory the bleach is supposed to be reflective and sort of glow under the blacklight. Let's see how this works
Okay now in theory the bleach is supposed to be reflective and sort of glow under the blacklight. Let's see how this works oh
Oh, it's the opposite of reflective
It's like it's black ink in the middle of the glowing white paper. That's cool
It's like it's black. Ink in the middle of the glowing white paper. That's cool
Weird I would not have guessed that was gonna happen
I thought it was gonna glow so that's interesting the bleach seems to sort of stop the
ultraviolet light from bouncing off of the paper
Permanently visible. It only shows up when someone uses the blacklight on it the lemon juice and the baking soda are both wonderful for sending
Concealed messages, but once they're revealed its permanently on the paper. If you use the blacklight in the bleach
Concealed messages, but once they're revealed its permanently on the paper if you use the blacklight in the bleach
It's only there when you've got the light on it
Something I like about using the bleach is that if you have a light of your own
There you have it three different methods of using invisible ink: Lemon juice which shows up under heat, baking soda and water
Which shows up a little bit with grape juice or also shows up with heat on it, and bleach
Which shows up a little bit with grape juice or also shows up with heat on it and bleach
But actually has the opposite effect. The paper around it glows and it stays nice and dark
But actually has the opposite effect the paper around it glows and it stays nice and dark
Looking at what you see. With the lemon juice or the baking soda ink
It's pretty hard to see what's going down on the paper because you can't heat it up and reveal it
Or it's no longer a secret now. Now you're all one step closer to becoming spies
Or it's no longer a secret now. You're all one step closer to becoming spies
This is a great activity for you to try at home
And it can be a fun way to send secret messages to your friends
Thank you for joining us for this experiment today, and we look forward to the next one. Talk to you then.
Don't think it's gonna catch on as a breath spray
Hey guys. Thanks for supporting Nate so much in these videos
I know this used to be grant Thompson the king of random but for years there have been so many things that I wanted to
Do for you that I just couldn't do by myself, but now that Nate's here helping out
I've got some room to breathe again which means a lot of fun new things coming your way.